so how are you doing really  well i'm looking at my i guess  ex-girlfriend right now still love each  other and we still  sorry  it's uh it's hard to move on i've always  been pretty independent slash  introverted and i never had a desire to  be with someone angel came around out of  nowhere i  told her i loved her in like the first  month and i don't think i told her  actually now that i'm remembering it i i  drew on her back that's my finger the  letter i and then a heart and then it  oh  that's so cute  it's good to talk about this and it's  good to let it out yeah  it's good to tell the world too but also  just to tell a stranger and and i know  she's watching me right now  tell her to